ON TIME SO I WANT TO BEGIN --
THE THE COMMITTEE ON ASSEMBLY
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE AS A SUB COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM.
AND IS ONE OF THE AUTHORS IS
HERE.
ALSO WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S
THE AUTHORS BIRTHDAY -- MISTER
WOOD.
COMPLETELY -- UNCONVENTIONAL BUT
NONE THE LESS HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO
YOU.
IF YOU MIND START JUMPING UP
HERE.
UP ALSO WANT TO NOTICE UP ALSO
WANT.
TO WELCOME ONCE AGAIN -- MISTER
OBERNOLTE HAD -- YOU'RE WELCOME
IS A COUPLE WORDS BE LIKE WAS
VICE CHAIR THAT'S ALWAYS AN
HONOR TO BE HERE IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND I'M LOOKING VERY
MUCH.
MUCH FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THIS YEAR.
ALL ANNOUNCED IN ADVANCE THAT MR
TEAM WILL BE THE SUBSTITUTE FOR
MR GARCIA TODAY ONLY -- SO YOU
MADE AGAINST WHAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
DEVASTATING FIRES THAT RAVAGED
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN THE STATE AND THE C. U.
P. THE P. YOU SEE A C. P. YOU
SEE HAVE FOCUS HEAVILY ON THE
UTILITIES RESPONSE TO THE
MASSIVE DESTRUCTION.
HOWEVER LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT
THE IMPACT THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS HAD ON THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS AND
HOW TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
HAVE RESPONDED.
OUR COMMUNICATION SYSTEM IS
VITAL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY YET AS
WE HAVE SEEN DURING THE
WILDFIRES IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
IT'S ONE OF OUR WEAKEST LINKS.
THIS SHOULD WORRY ALL OF US.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU THAT
THE FREQUENCY AND INTENSITY AND
SIZE OF THESE FIRES IS
INCREASING AT AN ALARMING RATE.
THERE'S GROWING NEED FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE CPUC AND OTHER
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AND THE
PUBLIC'S NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
EXTENT AND THE TIMING OF THE
RESTORATION EFFORTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ADEQUATE PREPARE FOR THE
INEVITABLE FUTURE COMMUNICATIONS
OUTAGES OUTAGES WHILE WE AGREE
THAT THE CPUC HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO COLLECT MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL.
THE CPUC IS NOT REQUIRED TO
REDUCE PRODUCE SUCH A REPORT.
ALTHOUGH THE CPUC OUR COMPLETE
INVOLUNTARY SUMMARY OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY
FIRES BY THE C. P. UC'S OWN
ADMISSION THEY BELIEVE THE
REPORT NEEDED TO BE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND DETAILED.
THIS BILL WOULD ANSWER THEIR
CALL FOR HELP BY GIVING THEM THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED AND TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO COLLECT MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL IS
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE FACT THAT THE
CPUC DID NOT PRODUCE A REPORT.
ON COMMUNICATION OUTAGES FOR THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CAN'T FIRE
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRE IN
STATE HISTORY.
SEE IF YOU SEE A STATED IN THEIR
ANALYSIS OF A PREVIOUS ITERATION
OF THIS BILL FROM LAST SESSION.
THAT THIS BILL PROPOSES A
COMPREHENSIVE DETAILED REPORT
AND ANNOUNCES OF AND ON AN ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
SOME COUNTY WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT CONDUCTED AN ALERT AND
WARNING DISASTER TEST IN
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR FUTURE DISASTERS.
REQUESTS WERE MADE TO SEVERAL
WIRELESS PROVIDERS PROTESTED
PAID IN THE EXERCISE AND PROVIDE
CELL TOWER INFORMATION.
THEY NEITHER PARTICIPATED IN THE
TESTER PROVIDED DATA ACCORDING
TO A REPORT COMMISSIONED BY
CINEMA COUNTY.
AB ONE EIGHTY THREE WOULD
REQUIRE THE CPUC TO REPORT TO
THE APPROPRIATE POLICY COMMITTEE
OF THE LEGISLATURE THE IMPACT OF
A NATURAL DISASTER ON THE
STATE'S TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK.
AND RESPONSE HOTEL COMISKEY
MCKAY COMMUNICATION COMPANIES
LET ME BE CLEAR WHAT THIS BILL
WILL NOT DO.
THE BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
DIVULGE INFORMATION TO BE
HARMFUL TO SECURITY SUCH AS
DISCLOSURE ADDRESSES A PROPOSED
NETWORK FACILITIES OR AN
ITEMIZED LIST OF EQUIPMENT
DEPLOYED.
EXISTING LAW UNDER P. YOU SEE --
CODE SECTION THREE OH FOUR
REQUIRES IT OF ANY INFORMATION.
PERCENT OF THIS BILL IS DEEMED
TO POSE A SECURITY THREAT THE
CPUC WOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
WITHHOLD SUB SUCH INFORMATION
FROM THE PUBLIC.
ADDITIONAL THIS BILL IS NOT A
MANDATE ON REAL TIME COLLECTION
OF DATA SPECIFIED IN THE REPORT.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS
REGION ACOSTA WITH TURN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK AND FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS.
WE HAVE REPRESENTED THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
CUSTOMERS INCLUDING TELEPHONE
CUSTOMERS.
AND ONE OF THE CORE ESSENTIAL
ISSUES OF OUR WORK HAS BEEN
ALWAYS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
RELIABLE UBIQUITOUS
COMMUNICATION BECAUSE IT'S SO
ESSENTIAL.
TO THE ABILITY TO CONTACT
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS.
IN TO RECEIVE ALERTS BUT IT'S
ALSO CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INDUSTRY THAT SUPPORTS MANY
ASPECTS OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND AS EXPLAINED BY SOME WOMEN
WOULD WITH THE CHANGES IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND THE OUTGROWTH OF
THESE LARGE FIRES THIS IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
I MEAN IT AB ONE EIGHTY THREE AT
ITS ESSENCE.
IS A BILL THAT WOULD HELP ALL OF
US MAKE SURE THAT NO
NEIGHBORHOOD OR COMMUNITY IS
LEFT BEHIND.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF A MAJOR
DISASTER THAT DAMAGES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES IT
WOULD ALLOW MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
AUTHORITIES TO ENSURE THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES ARE RECONNECTED.
ARM IT PROVIDES KEY PUBLIC
SAFETY INFORMATION THAT'S
CURRENTLY LACKEY.
ARM FOR EXAMPLE OFFER DISTRICTS
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY A WILDFIRE
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO OBTAIN.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THE CRITICAL COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE BOB SO THAT THEY
CAN FOR INSTANCE VERIFY THE
EFFORTS TO RESTORE THE SERVICE
DETERMINE WHETHER THE
RESTORATION IS ADEQUATE AND
TRULY MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
UP THEY CAN USE THE DATA TO
SUPPORT LOCAL AND REGIONAL
EFFORTS TO MITIGATE FUTURE
DAMAGE TO CRITICAL FACILITIES
AND BY DOING SO.
THAT INFORMATION IS ALSO USEFUL
FOR SHORING UP AN IMPROVING OUR
NINE ONE ONE ALERT SYSTEM.
ARMED.
THIS INFORMATION IS NOT
ROUTINELY AVAILABLE TODAY.
WE DON'T HAVE AS ASSEMBLYMAN
WOULD POINTED OUT WE DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION ON THE CAMPFIRE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION ON
CINEMA AND THEN TO SEE NO
COUNTIES BECAUSE THOSE COUNTIES
TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
GATHER THE INFORMATION.
ON THAT IS A TRIBUTE IN
CONGRATULATIONS TO THOSE
COUNTIES BUT THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO NEEDS TO BE ABLE.
TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF
IT'S A MAJOR WILDFIRE.
ON THE EXPERIENCES OF FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THOSE THAT RESIDE
IN THE AREAS WHERE THESE
EMERGENCIES HAVE DAMAGED
COMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES.
AND DISRUPTED SERVICE HAVE MADE
IT CLEAR THAT THE VOLUNTARY
MEASURES ARE JUST NOT ADEQUATE
AND THAT INCLUDES THE PROVISION
OF INFORMATION -- IT'S ESSENTIAL
THAT OUR LOCAL AND REGIONAL
AUTHORITIES OF A COMPLETE
UNDERSTANDING AND AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S A COMPLETE
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE IMPACTS OF THESE FIRES
AND BE ABLE TO VERIFY THAT IN
FACT THE SERVICES RESTORED.
THE RESEARCHER MEMBERS --
IGNITES YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT THINK THE ONLY THING
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND
MENTION IT IS IN FACT WHAT THE
PRIOR WITNESS.
ADDRESSED WHICH IS THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT ENSURING THAT
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS NOT LEFT BEHIND --
THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
EXAMPLES OVER THE YEARS NOT JUST
THE WILDFIRES BUT ALSO STE --
STORMS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WEATHER OUTAGES TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES AND
AFTER.
OF THE STORM IS OVER THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONFLICTING INFORMATION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT SERVICES
BEEN RESTORED IN ALL COMMUNITIES
IN ALL NEIGHBORHOODS.
ON THERE'S REALLY NO CENTRAL
LOCATION TO OBTAIN THAT
INFORMATION -- THERE'S NO REPORT
TO TURN TO SO THAT EVERYONE CAN
BE ASSURED BOTH -- LEGISLATORS
AND COMMUNITY ALIKE.
THAT THAT IN FACT SERVICE HAS
BEEN RESTORED WHAT IT TOOK TO
RESTORE -- OR IF THERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE COMMITTEES THAT
ARE STILL LEFT WITHOUT SERVICE --
AFTER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
GEARED. TO DOING ITS VERY NARROW
AS FAR AS UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS REPORT AS
INFORMATION BE COLLECTED AND
REPORTED THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU I THINK THE
NEED FOR IT IS REALLY
EXEMPLIFIED.
IF WE BROUGHT IN HERE
INDIVIDUALS OF WERE IMPACTED BY
THE WILDFIRES ARE IMPACTED BY A
NUMBER OF OTHER -- YOU KNOW
DECLARED EMERGENCIES AND IF THEY
ASKED YOU WHETHER OR NOT YOU
KNEW OR TURN CAN TURN TO
SOMETHING TO PROVE AND TO SHOW.
THAT SERVICE HAD BEEN RESTORED
IN ALL COMMUNITIES AND WHAT IT
TOOK TO DO THAT AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENED -- I I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AND RIGHT NOW WE
CAN'T POINT TO ANYWHERE TO
OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION IN AN
EASILY ACCESSIBLE MANNER.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THE
INFORMATION FLOWS AS THE SOMEONE
NUMBER MENTIONED THIS IS NOT
REAL TIME COLLECTION WHICH WE
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW TO DO THAT THIS IS
AFTER THE FACT.
AND THIS IS A WAY TO ENSURE.
THAT EVERYONE IS COVERED NO
COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT BEHIND IN A
WAY TO PREPARE GOING FORWARD SO
FOR THOSE REASONS BORN SUPPORT
THE BILL [inaudible]
CORPORATE.
THANK YOU ARE NOTICING THAT
THERE'S A QUORUM -- PRESENT
MADAM SECRETARY -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
BUT A WHOLE THAT FEAR
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
PRO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
WE HAVE A FOUR THANK YOU HAVE A
QUORUM ALSO NOTICING THE MISTER --
BRO HAS NOW JOINED THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. FOR PARTICIPATING AND
THIS IS A BEEN A **** BATH THANK
BOERNER HORVATH THANK YOU.
A B. H. FOR SHORT [inaudible]
TV [inaudible]
EIGHT TBH.
I'M ANY ADDITIONAL WILL --
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
DEAR SANDERS REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
FORMALLY THE OFFICER REPAIR
ADVOCATES WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU.
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANKS.
LEVINE REPRESENTING AT AND T.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
THEM OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
IN DISCUSSING DIFFERENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE LEGISLATION
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT
REACHED A COMMON GROUND ON THIS
BILL AND SO THEREFORE WE REMAIN
OPPOSED -- TODAY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AS YOU'VE
HEARD FREQUENTLY HAS BROAD
AUTHORITY TO COLLECT NETWORK
INFORMATION IT DEEMS NECESSARY
TO INVESTIGATE OUTAGES.
AND NETWORK PERFORMANCE.
BOTH DURING.
AND AFTER DECLARED EMERGENCIES I
MIGHT ALSO ADD THAT EIGHTEEN T.
IS ONE OF MANY AS ALL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES ARE CARRIERS OF LAST
RESORT WHERE WE ARE REQUIRED BY
LAW. TO RESTORE ALL SERVICES TO
COMMUNITIES AND WERE REQUIRED TO
BE ACT OR BETTER THAN THE
SERVICES PRIOR TO THE DISASTER.
THE P.YOU SEE ALSO HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO REQUEST DATA ON
COMPETITIVE SERVICES THAT THEY
DO NOT REGULATE.
AND SO AS A RESULT IT'S VERY
VERY IMPORTANT THAT KEY
INFORMATION.
THAT IS NON REGULATED
COMPETITIVE OR PROPRIETARY OR
RELATED TO HOMELAND SECURITY.
BE MAINTAINED AS CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION NOW WHAT WAS NOT
MENTIONED HERE TODAY IS RECENTLY.
THE P. YOU SEE REFORMED ITS
RULES.
SIXTY SIXTY REFORM IT'S RULES ON
HOW IT WILL TREAT.
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION RELATED
TO THESE TYPES OF DISASTERS AND
SO IN SOME INSTANCES INFORMATION
COULD BE READILY MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC AND IN OTHER
INSTANCESIT MUST REMAIN
CONFIDENTIAL BUT THERE IS A
PROCESS OF FOR DUE PROCESS. FOR
INFORMATION TO BE RELEASED IF
IT'S DEEMED UP PUBLIC A BY THE
COMMISSION -- WE BELIEVE ONE
EIGHTY THREE MISTER WOODS BILL
WOULD UNDERCUT THE BALANCE OF
THE FRAMEWORK THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED.
BY EXEMPTING ANNUAL REPORTS FROM
EXISTING CONFIDENTIALITY
SAFEGUARDS.
IN ADDITION WE BELIEVE IT
IGNORES ROBUST DISASTER RESPONSE
PROCESSES ALREADY IN PLACE AND
CLEAR PUBLIC VIEW.
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE IS
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE -- ARE
AND A STRONG NETWORK WHEN OUR
CONSTRUCTION TEAMS BUILD CELL
SITES IN DISASTER PRONE AREAS
ALL OF THEM ALL OF THEM ARE
BUILT TO MEET OR EXCEED STATE
STRUCTURAL STANDARDS.
THROUGH THE MULTIPLE WILDFIRES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
IN RECENT YEARS WE HAVE DEPLOYED
HUNDREDS OF TECHNICIANS AND A
STATEWIDE FLEET OF MOBILE
EMERGENCY FACILITIES WHERE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS DAMAGED THE
IDEA THAT WE LEAVE
CONSTITUENCIES WITHOUT SERVICE.
IS NOT REFLECTED IN THE REALITY.
EVEN AS THE WILD FIRES RAGED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE PROVIDE MOBILE PHONES
CHARGING STATIONS AND SATELLITE
BASED WIRELESS SITES. TO BOTH
FIRST RESPONDERS AS WELL AS
IMPACTED CONSTITUENCIES.
JUST LAST MONTH WE HAD ON THE
LAWN OF THE CAPITOL THE EIGHTEEN
T. DISASTER RECOVERY TEAM.
WITH PROFESSIONAL TECHNICIANS TO
DEMONSTRATE THE KINDS OF
CAPABILITIES THAT WE BRING. TO
THESE EMERGENCY SERVICES AND I
MIGHT ADD ALL OF THAT IS DONE AT
THE COMPANY'S EXPENSE.
NO STATE AGENCY I KNOW LOCAL
AGENCY NOR ANY CONSUMER IS EVER
BUILD FOR THE KINDS OF SERVICES
THAT WE DO IN TERMS OF IMMEDIATE
SERVICE AS WELL AS RESTORATION
OF SERVICES.
SO AS A RESULT WE DON'T BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY AND
THEREFORE AT THIS TIME WE OPPOSE
THE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BERNIE
OROZCO WITH CABLE ASSOCIATION.
ONE A PIGGYBACK OFF WOOD MISTER
DEVINE HAS SAID SO BASICALLY
WHAT YOU HAVE TODAY IS UNDER
CURRENT STATUTE THE P. C.'S
ABILITY TO GET THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION THEY HAVE THAT
THERE'S THREE CODE SECTIONS THAT
ALLOW THEM TODAY. TO GET THAT
INFORMATION AND THEY CAN PUT
THAT IN THERE AND REPORT.
MIKE LIKE MR LINE SAID THERE'S
ALSO ANOTHER CODE SECTION FIVE
EIGHT THREE THAT MAKE SURE THAT
THAT INFORMATION IS CONFIDENTIAL
ONLY RELEASE IF IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO RELEASE THAT INFORMATION.
SO AS FAR AS HIS BILL THAT
PIECES DOESN'T THE IS
UNNECESSARY.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL ASKS FOR
BEYOND WHAT IS ON THE CURRENT
LAW IT ASKS FOR THE TYPE OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE BEING
RESTORED.
AND I LISTEN TO THE PROPONENTS
SOLICITED AUTHORED A SAID WHAT
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S
COMING BACK WHAT'S COMING IN BUT
WE JUST TALK ABOUT THAT BEING
CONFIDENTIAL IT'S A COMPETITIVE
MARKET.
I WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO KNOW WHAT MR DEVINE'S DOING
HIS BUSINESS SO THAT I CAN
COMPETE WITH HIM IF I THINK HE I
HAVE A BETTER PRODUCT AND WHAT
HE HAS.
I WILL SWOOP IN AND COMPETE WITH
HIM BUT EVERYONE HAS ONLY SO
MUCH CAPITAL FOR THEIR
FACILITIES EXPANSION.
SO HAVING THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION MADE PUBLIC TO THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
IS INAPPROPRIATE IT'S A
COMPETITIVE MARKET.
IF ANYTHING THIS BILL IS SORT OF
A SLIGHT AT THE P. YOU SEE THAT
THEY HAVE NOT DONE WHAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING I THINK I
THINK I'VE HEARD THAT SAID A
COUPLE TIMES HERE.
AND I LISTEN TO PROPONENTS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN WILL MAKE IS
THAT -- WILL MAKE IS WORKSHOPS
AT THE P. YOU SEE.
THIS STUFF COULD BE TO DISCUSS
THEIR AT THAT TIME THAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE MOMENT TO BRING THAT
INFORMATION UP.
WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
PROCEEDINGS AT THE P. YOU SEE
WHERE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT FIRES
AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WERE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSES AND
EVERYONE HAS WEIGHED IN ON THAT.
THIS BILL COMPLEX WITH THOSE
EFFORTS.
IF THIS BILL PASSES IT CONFLICTS
WITH WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW SO THE
WILDFIRES HAS GENERATED A LOT OF
WORK AT THE PC.
AND THIS DOES NOTHING MORE THAN
TO COMPETE WITH THAT.
SO IT'S ALREADY AUTHORIZED UNDER
CURRENT LAW FOR INFORMATION IT
CAN ALREADY BE SHARED IF IT'S
DEEMED APPROPRIATE UNDER PUBLIC
UTILITIES CONSTRUCTION.
FIVE EIGHTY THREE WHAT THIS ASK
FOR IS TO MAKE PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION AVAILABLE.
AND TO SHARE THAT WITH OTHERS SO
THE COMMUNITY KNOWS WHAT IS
BEING RESTORED THAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
POSTED.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON FOR C. K. A THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
I WANTED TO KIND OF TAKE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT DIRECTION HERE --
I'LL BE BRIEF -- THE SUGGESTION
IS AND I KNOW IT WASN'T --
MISTER WHAT SUGGESTION BUT THE
SUGGESTION FROM THE SOME OF THE
WITNESSES SAID THAT SOMEHOW OR
OTHER.
THE INDUSTRY IS SLOW TO RESPOND
SLOW TO RESTORE -- NOT DOING
THEIR JOB -- WE TAKE SOME OF THE
BRIDGE AT THAT -- MY THINK OF MR
DEVINE INDICATED OF THE WIRELESS
CARRIERS HAVE DONE AN
UNBELIEVABLE JOB COMING BACK IN
AFTERWARDS -- ACTUALLY WARNING
BEFOREHAND COMING BACK IN
AFTERWARDS AND THERE'S EVERY
INTEREST IN THE WORLD FOR THEM
TO DO THAT NOT.
PARTLY IT'S HUMANITARIAN THE
OTHER PART IS COMPETITIVE YOU
WANT TO GET YOUR SYSTEM BACK UP
AND IN LINE SO YOU'RE BECAUSE SO
YOU HAVE CUSTOMERS AGAIN SO.
WE UNDERSTAND WHERE MISTER
WHAT'S COMING FROM THIS AND WE
CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE WITH
EVERYTHING HIS DISTRICT AS GOD
THROUGH BUT WE JUST DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE APPROACH
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY STATED THIS BEFORE A
MASS FOR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY I DIDN'T WANNA
STOP THE FIRST PERSON THAT IN
STATE THAT BUT I'LL DO THAT FROM
HERE ON OUT THANKS.
THIS CHAIR REMEMBERS DOMINIC
TOMARI OF HERE ON BEHALF OF
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS. FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED WE
ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ACCURACY ON BEHALF OF VERIZON
ALSO RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES WAS OBERNOLTE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF THE SOMEONE WHAT
I WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE ASSERTIONS MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION -- ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY REYES AND
IT'S A CONCERN THAT I SHARE IS
THIS CONCERN OVER A LACK OF
CONFIDENTIALITY.
THROUGH THIS ALTERNATIVE PATHWAY
FOR THE RELEASE OF INFORMATION
ANDA ONE OF THE EXAMPLES I WAS
THINKING ABOUT.
IS IF A TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANY HAD INFRASTRUCTURE
DESTROYED IN A NATURAL DISASTER.
AND THEN.
CHOSE TO INSTALL AN UPGRADED
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN THEY WHO IN
RESPONSE NATIONAL DISASTER THAT
ENABLE THEM TO COMPETE IN
ANOTHER MARKET LIKE ALSO PROVIDE.
INTERNET SERVICE OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT -- ISN'T THAT VALUABLE
INFORMATION THAT THEY WOULDN'T
WANT THEIR COMPETITORS TO HAVE.
SO I I JUST WONDER IF THERE
ISN'T SOME MIDDLE GROUND HERE
THAT WE CAN GET TO A PLACE WHERE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT RELEASING THAT
INFORMATION THAT THEY CONSIDER
CONFIDENTIAL.
HI I THAT IS NOT MY INTENT TO
READ TO YOU KNOW TO RELEASE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION --
CERTAINLY FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
SECURITY AS WELL AS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT THAT'S
NOT THE INTENT AT ALL SO IF
THERE IS IF THERE IS A LACK OF
CLARITY THERE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. TO CLARIFY THAT THAT
IS NOT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DISASTER --
HOW CAN WE IMPROVE I MEAN DOES
ANYBODY?
DO WE NOT WANT TO LEARN FROM
FROM DISASTERS AND MAKE THINGS
BETTER -- AND WITHOUT A DETAILED
REPORT ON WHAT HAPPENED HOW MANY
PEOPLE WENT OUT HOW LONG WERE
THEY OUT -- WHERE WERE THE
OUTAGES HOW DO WE LEARN FROM
THAT FROM IN THE PAST WHERE DO
WE GO BACK AND REBUILD EXIT
THINGS EXACTLY THE WAY WE BUILT
THEM -- AND IN THE FUTURE AND
HOPE FOR DIFFERENT RESULT IN THE
FUTURE SO -- AND I WOULD I WOULD
SAY ALSO YOU KNOW I THINK THERE
IS A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
MIGHT HAPPEN IN AN URBAN AREA
AND WHAT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN A
RURAL AREA.
SO WE HAVE A BIG STORMS AND
THINGS ALL THE TIME IN OUR AREA
AND I WILL TELL YOU -- QUITE
FRANKLY WE DO HEAR FROM
CONSUMERS -- FREQUENTLY -- THAT
WOW BUT I'VE BEEN WITHOUT MY
SERVICE FOR TWO THREE WEEKS --
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW I RECOGNIZE
IT'S DIFFICULT SOMETIMES FOR
CARRIERS TO GET THERE BUT IT
ISN'T LIKE WHAT HAPPENS IN IN AN
URBAN AREA WHERE SERVICE CAN GET
UP PRETTY QUICKLY -- YOU KNOW I
SAY THIS OFTEN YOU KNOW IN IN
MANY MY AREAS SOMETIMES WORK
WORK WORK WE'RE HAPPY WITH ONE
GEE I JUST NOTICED ON MY PHONE I
GOT FIVE G. NOW I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT I DID KNOW THAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
BUT WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE ROBUST ACTIVE ACCESS
AND AND I YOU KNOW I HAVE I HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS JUST IN GENERAL
ABOUT -- HOW HOW SOME OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS MIGHT WORK I
WAS FAR AS EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
HOW CAN WE IMPROVE UPON THAT WE
HAD BIG WE WHEN CERTAIN TOWERS
MIGHT GO DOWN IT MIGHT AFFECT
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE?
IN THE MOST RECENT DISASTER IN
OUR DISTRICT -- OF FLOODING IN
AND THE BULLS THE LITTLE CITY OF
GARDEN GO.
THAT'S NOT A BIG CITY IS FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
OUT THERE.
ON A GOOD DAY THEY HAVE TERRIBLE
CELL COVERAGE.
AND IT WAS A HUGE PROBLEM FOR
FEMA AND YES AND OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS TO TO T. EVEN
COMMUNICATE.
NOT TO THE CREDIT OF THE
CARRIERS AND I AND I AND I'M
VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT THEY DID
DEPLOY -- OR UNITS AS MUCH AS AS
MISTER DEVINE SAID THAT'S GREAT
AND SO FOR ABOUT A WEEK.
THE PEOPLE IN THE RIVER
COMMITTEE HAD THE BEST CELL
PHONE COVERAGE THEY'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED IN OUR LIFE.
AND IT'S GONE NOW.
BUT OF THE SO -- YOU KNOW AND
THAT'S JUST THE NATURE OF THE
SOME SAID THAT THE WERE WE LIVE
IN SO IS NOT MY DESIRE TO TO
EXPOSE ANYBODY'S PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION MY DESIRE TO SEE.
THAT THINGS GET REBUILT -- IN A
WAY THAT WE LEARNED FROM ART
FROM THE HISTORY OF OF THESE
INCIDENTS AND THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE FOR EVERYBODY SICK.
OUT CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
ALL ON THE SAME PAGE ABOUT THAT
SO I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I'LL BE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TODAY
BECAUSE OF MY CONCERNS BUT I
WOULD LOVE TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE.
WE COULD A PROTECT THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY CONSIDER
CONFIDENTIAL AND STILL BE ABLE --
TO PUBLICLY CONSIDERED HOW BEST
TO RESPOND TO THESE DISASTERS
ABSOLUTELY.
I TBH AS ALL PRIVATE NON.
THANK YOU -- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL -- I THINK
YOU KNOW WE DO ALL WANT TO LEARN
FROM DISASTERS AND I WANT TO ASK
THE AUTHOR FIRST OF ALL -- WE'VE
HEARD THAT THE CPC CAN'T ALREADY
COLLECT THIS INFORMATION -- DID
YOU REVIEW THAT DATA COLLECTION
HAS IT HAPPENED IS IS.
MORE OF A PROBLEM THE CPUC I
THINK IT'S CHALLENGES IS
RESOURCES QUITE FRANKLY -- SI PC
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FIRES DID DID DO A REPORT -- AND
I THINK YOU AS YOU HEARD FROM --
MY WITNESS HERE -- AT THE CINEMA
COUNTY MENDOCINO COUNTY --
DOODLE COLLECTED A LOT OF A LOT
OF INFORMATION BUT THEY WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO HAVE DONE A DEEPER
DIVE QUITE FRANKLY.
AND THERE HAS BEEN NO REPORT ON
THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
FIRES BIG AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT SO PART OF THIS
IS IS IS RESOURCES AND SO.
SORE ASKING FOR INFORMATION
PRESSING FOR INFORMATION FROM
THE CARRIERS TO HELP.
HELP US TO LEARN FROM THESE
THESE -- THESE DISASTERS.
THANK YOU -- I I SYMPATHIZE WITH
THE ISSUES ANY IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRING UP
THE ISSUE BETWEEN.
URBAN AND RURAL AREAS AND I
THINK EVEN HAD SOMEBODY -- WENT
AND SPEAK OUR US SOMEBODY SPEAK --
TALKING ABOUT IN URBAN AREAS
THERE'S SO MUCH COMPETITION.
THAT THEY WILL GET RESTORED
NATIONALLY -- AND I'M NOT SURE
THIS INFORMATION WHICH IS A LOT
OF GATHERING OF INFORMATION
ABOUT THE STATE.
STATE IS NECESSARY AND MORE
URBAN AREAS I DO SEE THERE'S AN
ISSUE -- WITH RURAL AREAS
THERE'S ALWAYS AN ISSUE WITH
ROLL COVERAGE -- I THINK THAT'S
A KIND OF A WORLDWIDE ISSUE AND
NOT JUST -- CALIFORNIA UNITED
STATES -- SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
INCOME OPPOSITION AND REALLY YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S A WAY TO DRAW
DOWN ON LESS INFORMATION HOW TO
BE REPORTED IT'S GREAT THAT YOU
WANT TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION.
AROUND THE PROPRIETARY THING
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING WAS REALLY.
VALID -- AS WELL AS NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUES -- YOU KNOW
THOSE THOSE ARE THINGS ALL THE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TODAY
BUT I'M I'M LOOKING FOR TO YOU
WORKING WITH.
FOLKS ON THIS AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET TO A PLACE OF YES.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
WE WOULD NEED A FIRST AND A
SECOND [inaudible]
SECOND.
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
ARE JUST A YOUNG I THINK JUST IN
GENERAL -- THE NETWORKS ARE
VITAL PUBLIC SAFETY -- AND THEY
HAVE PROVEN TO BE OUR WEAKEST
LINK -- WE CAN CHANGE THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASTA APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO BUT A WHOLE THAT.
BUT HOLE BUT NO BONTA
[inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RODRIGUEZ.
MUCH AS A WHOLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT THAT THE LONG HAUL I NOTICE
MR GABRIEL IS OUT THERE.
I READ A PRESENT ON AB
[inaudible]
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO YEAH.
WE HAVE A FILE ITEM SIX AB
ELEVEN THIRTY TO MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
PLEASED TODAY 2% AB ELEVEN
THIRTY TWO WHICH WILL HELP
CRACKDOWN ON CALLER ID FRAUD.
THE ACT OF MISREPRESENTING
CALLER ID INFORMATION ON A
CERTAIN THING AGAIN.
HAS BECOME FAR TOO COMMON
IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO
CALL RECIPIENTS.
NEW SMARTPHONE APPLICATIONS AND
WEBSITES SUBMITS PERFECT MUCH
EASIER.
AND WHAT CONGRESS PASSED THE
TRUTH IN CALLER ID ACT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THE LAW DOES NOT
CAPTURE THE FULL RANGE OF
NEFARIOUS ACTIVITY.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES
THIS PROBLEM OF VIOLATION CAN
RESULT IN A CIVIL PENALTY OF UP
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
VIOLATION ENFORCEABLE BY CITY
ATTORNEYS DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OR
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ REPRESENTING
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MAINTENANCE IS SUPPORT%
YEAH VERY BRIEFLY -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN PERCENT NESTOR
HERNANDEZ AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL BUT ALSO ON BEHALF
OF TURN -- IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- I THINK AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM --
ID SPOOFING IS GROWING PROBLEM --
NOT JUST HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
IN OTHER STATES AS WELL -- WHAT
WAS CRAFTED IN THIS BILL IS A
VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE WHERE WE
HAVE -- PHONES MOVING OCCURRING
WHERE IT IS YOU SEE EXAMPLES
HERE -- OF THE CALLER ID IT'S
TURNING UP TO SEE PHONE NUMBERS
ACTUAL PHONE NUMBERS FOR THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO FOR EXAMPLE --
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY AIRPORT --
IN THE LIKELY FOR REPORTS FROM --
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS AND SAN
DIEGO SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
APPEAR THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
SO WITH THIS BILL GETS TO IS
JUST MAKING CLEAR THAT THAT IS
NOT ALLOWED IN CALIFORNIA YOU
CAN NOT A PHONE SPOOF -- PHONE
NUMBER FOR A LOCAL OR STATE --
ENTITY AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK FOR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OF WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
ANY MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ASSUMING THERE'S NO --
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES MISS OBERNOLTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SOMEONE I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU ON THE BILL IT'S
DEFINITELY ADDRESSES A PROBLEM
THAT.
IS -- VERY DIRE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK THAT A
LOT OF OUR CONSTITUENTS WHEN YOU
RAKE THE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT -- ROBO
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S SOMETHING WE
AT THE STATE LEVEL SOMETIMES ARE
POWERLESS TO ADDRESS BECAUSE SO
MUCH IS FEDERALLY PREEMPTED ****.
I THINK YOU FOUND A VERY
WORTHWHILE ISSUE TO GO AFTER
HERE WOULD LOVE TO BE LISTED AS
A CO AUTHOR WHEN YOU GET THE
OPPORTUNITY IF THAT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU.
ABSOLUTELY WOULD BE A PLEASURE I
JOIN AGREE THIS IS SOMETHING I
HEAR A LOT ABOUT FROM FOLKS BACK
IN MY COMMUNITY AND LIKELY WERE
IN A POSITION WHERE -- THE STATE
LAWS NOT PRINTED THAT'S EXPLICIT
IN THE FEDERAL STATUTE AND SO WE
HAVE AN OPPOSITE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT WOULD.
BE VERY PLEASED TO HAVE YOU AS A
CO AUTHORS OF THANK YOU.
IT IS SO QUESTIONS.
MAY ALSO BE JOINED AS A CO
AUTHOR YES SIR WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DUPONT'S TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BURN A HOLE THAT.
BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I CERVANTES TING.
HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
LOOKS OVER I RODRIGUEZ. FIVE
RUMORS A SO CALLED. FIVE ZERO
MEASURES ON CALL MISTER
OBERNOLTE I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER --
AUTHORS.
MISTER PATTERSON AYE BY
APOLOGIZE IT'S LOOK THAT WAY
FIRST. FOR NO OTHER REASON
PLEASE ONLY BECAUSE I'VE CALLED
ON YOUR FIRST THEY WERE.
LOOKING THIS WAY IF YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT THIS PATTERSON AND NORTH
AUTHORED.
AVAILABLE JUDGE PERCENT
[inaudible]
THANKS.
THIS OVERALL TO BE PRESENTING ON
AB.
EIGHT EIGHTY MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AB
EIGHT TAKE EIGHTY MAKES
MODIFICATIONS TO A SECTION OF
THE TRANSPORTATION CODE.
THAT WAS FIRST CODIFIED TWO
YEARS AGO BY SOMEONE AND COOPER
IT'S SIMPLY LEAVES OUT THE
CRIMES THAT MAKE ONE INELIGIBLE
TO DRIVE FOR A TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANY.
HITHIS BILL CORRECTS A DRAFTING
ERROR IN THAT ORIGINAL BILL THAT
A RONI SLEE MENTION TWO SECTIONS
OF THE CRIMINAL CODE THE DON'T
ACTUALLY CONTAIN CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS THIS BILL SIMPLY.
ELIMINATES REFERENCES TO THOSE
CODES I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR WORKING WITH ME IN
THE BILL AND YET THE TIME AND
ATTENTION BY YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF -- WILL CERTAINLY ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT -- BUT
OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE TO MAKE
THE BILL BETTER AND CLARIFY THE
INTENT.
WELL THE FIRST IN A SECOND -- I
DON'T SEE ANY MAIN -- WITNESS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
[inaudible]
AND SUPPORT.
ANY MAN ON HIS WITNESSES.
SOME THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WELL FIRST OR SECOND MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
SPECIAL REQUESTS DRIVE A MAN SIX
TWO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FORCES DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE BY OBERNOLTE AYE BUT A
WHOLE THAT.
BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I CERVANTES TING.
HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RESERVATIONS. FIVE ZERO MEASURES
ON CALL MISTER PATTERSON WOULD
YOU.
PLEASE A PRESENT
.
THANK CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS UP.
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN THAT WILL MAKE
A SUPPOSED SIMPLE CHANGE TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE.
A HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE
THEM CALIFORNIA CPUC OPERATES
MULTIPLE DEAF AND DISABLED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAMS ONE
OF THOSE BEING THE CALIFORNIA
PHONES PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM%
SERVES MORE THAN. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
DEAF OR DISABLED PROVIDING THEM
WITH TELEPHONES IT MAY HAVE
LARGER BUTTONS TO MAKE DIALING
EASIER YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
THE APPLICATIONS.
THIS APPLICANTS TO THE PROGRAM
MUST HAVE A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
CERTIFIED THEIR NEED SIGN OFF ON
THEIR APPLICATIONS CURRENT
STATUTE IDENTIFIES POSITIONS
SPEAKS LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST.
APAMA TRISTEN POSITION
ASSISTANCE HAS CERTIFIED
PROVIDERS OF THE CURRENT LIST
EXCLUDES NURSE PRACTICAL
PRACTITIONERS WHO OFTEN SERVE AS
THE FRONTLINE PROVIDED MANY
COMMUNITIES WITH.
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGES A
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL PARTS OF
THE STATE.
A TOP DATING THE CO TWO NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO THE LIST OF
CERTIFIED PROVIDERS.
IS REALLY A SIMPLE FIX THAT'S
GOING TO ENSURE ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM DOES NOT IMPEDE. FOR
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA REGULARLY SEE A NURSE
PRACTITIONER FOR THEIR PRIMARY
CARE NEEDS HERE WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS CHRISTY
WISE.
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND THE CAP THE
RENTAL A NURSE PRACTITIONER AND
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF NURSING
AT FRESNO STATE.
WELL FIRST.
WELL FIRST A SECOND.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WHAT IS
THIS.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE DUNCAN
AFTERNOON I SERVE ON THE
LEGISLATIVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORST
LEADERSHIP COALITION FRESNO.
I'M ALSO PRACTICING NURSE
PRACTITIONER THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN LOOKING AT THE
RED ORIGINAL PUBLIC UTILITY CODE
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE I THINK IT
WAS JUST AN OVERSIGHT THAT NURSE
PRACTITIONERS A LAPTOP THIS CODE.
I HAVE TWO REASONS FOR THIS
FIRST THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
PRACTICE POLICY THE GENDER
PRISON SECTION FIVE THREE EIGHT
ZERO ZERO IDENTIFIES PRIMERICA
BUYERS AS PHYSICIANS NON
PHYSICIANS.
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS.
THESE PRATER PROVIDERS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE
WITHIN THE SCOPE OTHER PRACTICE
INCLUDING REFERRALS.
BASED ON THIS CALIFORNIA
PRACTICE POLICY CODE IF
ASSISTANCE ASSISTANCE WHO IS THE
MIDDLE OF A PROVIDER.
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO CERTIFIED
INDIVIDUALS NEED AND SIGN THE
APPLICATION FOR THIS PROGRAM
THEN IT STANDS TO REASON THE
NURSE PRACTITIONER ALSO A MIDDLE
OF A PROVIDER.
SHOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO DO AS
WELL.
SECONDLY THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONAL CODE ARTICLE
EIGHT SECTION THREE A TWO EIGHT
THREE SIX POINT ONE STATES.
NEITHER THIS CHAPTER OR ANY
OTHER PROVISION OF LAW SHALL BE
CONSTRUED TO PROHIBIT A NURSE
PRACTITIONER FROM FOR NURSING
FORWARDING DRUGS OR DEVICES. ONE
OF THE FOLLOWING APPLY THIS
MEANS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STANDARDIZED PROCEDURES BETWEEN
THE NURSE PRACTITIONER IN THE
POSITION.
AND THE DRUGS AND DEVICES ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRACTITIONERS EDUCATIONAL AND
CLINICAL COMPETENCY.
BASED ON THIS CALIFORNIA CODE
DIAGNOSING PRESCRIBING TREATING
AN ORDER THREE MEDICAL DEVICES
AS WELL WITHIN THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
UPDATING THE POLICY OF THE
UTILITY CO TO INCLUDE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO LIST TO CERTIFY
PROVIDERS WILL NOT ONLY CORRECT
THIS OVERSIGHT.
IT WILL ALSO MORE IMPORTANTLY
ENSURE ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM
FOR QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS IN
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN AREAS WHO
TYPICALLY HAVE ACCESS TO ONLY A
NURSE PRACTITIONER AS A PRIME
PROVIDER.
I TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE FOR A. B. FIFTEEN FOURTEEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
CHRISTY WE SOME BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND SUPPORT AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES A
SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK OR TURN IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ASSUMING THERE'S NO OPPOSITION --
ADDITIONAL POSITION WITNESSES
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
NOW THAT MY CLOSE THANK YOU FOR
THE VOTE.
THANK YOUNG HOPEFUL YOUR BILL
BILL GETS OUT AS A VERY
SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE I'M ALSO
HOPEFUL THAT MINE WILL GET OUT
WITH TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
A REALITY [inaudible]
EXACTLY RIGHT -- MA'AM SIX A
PLEASE CALL ROLE [inaudible]
YEAH.
MOTIONS DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BURN A HOLE THAT
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
BROUGH I CERVANTES.
TING.
HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW.
PATTERSON AYE PATTERSON AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
SILVA I RODRIGUEZ.
MEASURE SOME CALL.
MEASURES ON CALL -- STRUCTURE
WOULD YOU TAKE THE GAVEL -- THE
BILL [inaudible]
THEIR SECOND [inaudible] SEVEN
THE CHURCH OF SATAN [inaudible]
FOR THE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DISCUSSION I WILL SECOND.
MR SANTIAGO YOU'RE PRESENTING ON
AB NINETY SEVEN F..
I THINK MISTER I HAVE A PRESENT
TODAY ON FOR NINETY SEVEN WHEN
SOMEONE HAS THIS ABILITY WE
WANTED THEM TO HAVE SOMETHING
SIMPLE THAT WE TAKE FOR GRANTED
OFTEN WHICH IS ON THE PHONE --
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE IT -- FOR SOCIAL
RECREATIONAL AND ALSO FOR LIFE
THREATENING EXPERIENCES IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY THAT THEY
HAVE A PHONE.
AND A DEFINITE STABLE PROGRAMS
PROVIDED A CRITICAL EQUIPMENT
AND SERVICES TO PEOPLE -- THE IT
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR FAMILY
FRIENDS FOR HEALTH CARE REASONS
AND PERFECT AND SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS ALSO WOULD NEED IF
THEY'RE IN THAT FIELD.
HOW WE WANT TO CONTINUE THIS
PROGRAM THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A
BEEF -- FOR NINETY SEVEN TODAY
AND I WOULD SPECIALLY I TRIED
OUT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AIR CARRIERS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH THE ARE CAN
YOU SEE P. CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
TURN IN SUPPORT.
YES SANDERS SON ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MANY MEMBERS.
MR SANTIAGO JULY TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FORBUT YES
VOTE MISTER.
SO WE HAVE A FIRST AND SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
QUESTION IS TO PASTA
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SANTIAGO.
HI SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING BUT A WHOLE
THAT [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
BROWN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CERVANTES TING [inaudible]
HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NOT BURDEN.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SO.
CALLED.
EXPERTS FOUR ZERO THAT BILL IS
ON CALL
THIS IS LIKE PERCENT
[inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
HAVE YOU PRESENT ON I EIGHTY
NINE ONE ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE ELEVEN CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
IS HOME TO EIGHT MILLION PERSON
PEOPLE WHO ARE EITHER OLDER
ADULTS.
ARE PERSONS WITH MOBILITY
CENTURY INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL AND OR MENTAL
HEALTH DISABILITIES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE CONSIDERED
AT RISK WHO HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS.
AND REGULARLY REQUIRE SPECIAL
ACCOMMODATIONS ESPECIALLY DURING
CASES OF EMERGENCY WERE THEY MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO CLEARLY
COMMUNICATE WITH FOR FOR
SPONSORS.
IN ORDER TO BEST SERVE THOSE WHO
NEED.
WHO NEED HELP AND MINIMIZE ANY
RISK OF INJURY IT IS CRITICAL
THAT OFFER FOR SPONSORS FIRED
LAW ENFORCEMENT EMS?
BE PROVIDED WITH A PERSON'S
VITAL HEALTH INFORMATION PART
ARRIVING ON SCENE.
AB NINE ELEVEN WERE DIRECT CAL --
YES TO ESTABLISH A SMART.
NINE ONE ONE TYPE SYSTEM THAT
ENABLES AT RISK INDIVIDUALS TO
VOLUNTARY DISCLOSE IMPORTANT.
HEALTH INFORMATION TO BE
AVAILABLE TO FIRST RESPONDERS.
HOW THE INFORMATION WOULD
INCLUDE MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND
MEDICATIONS PHOTOGRAPHS AND
EMERGENCY CONTACTS EACH BEING A
CRITICAL PIECE OF INFORMATION
FOR OUR FIRST RESPONDERS?
MEMBERS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
UPGRADING ITS NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM TO NEXT GEN TECHNOLOGY.
WILL BE CAPABLE OF PERFORMING
THE FUNCTIONS OF A SMART NINE
ONE SYSTEM AT DESCRIBED IN THIS
BILL.
WITH ME TODAY PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IS JAMIE HUDSON A DISPATCHER
WHAT THE ELK GROVE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND AFTER DOING A GOT FROM U. D.
W. [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JAMIE HUDSON A
DISPATCH SUPERVISOR FOR THE OAK
GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
I'M ALSO THE STATE COORDINATOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TELE
COMMUNICATOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TASKFORCE WHICH IS OUR STATE'S
DISPATCH MUTUAL AID PROGRAM.
I'VE BEEN A DISPATCHER FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO THE GROW
POLICE DEPARTMENT PARTNERED WITH
THE COMPANY TO OFFER A SMART
NINE ONE ONE SERVICE TO THE
CITIZENS OF ELK GROVE.
THE DESIRE WAS TO OFFER A SYSTEM
WHICH ALLOWED VOLUNTARY PROFILE
CREATION FOR CITIZENS.
WHO WANTED OUR NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
PARTICULAR INFORMATION IF ANY OF
THEIR REGISTERED TELEPHONE
NUMBERS CALLED NINE ONE ONE FROM
WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION?
THIS WAS RESULT OF OUR AGENCY
WANTING TO OFFER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES TO A
VARIETY OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WITH DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES OR
NEEDS. FOR INSTANCE WE WANTED A
FASTER WAY FOR CALLERS FROM OUR
DEAF COMMUNITY TO COMMUNICATE
INITIAL INFORMATION TO US.
WE ALSO WANTED PARENTS OF
JUVENILE AND DEPENDENT ADULTS.
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN DEPENDENT
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO STORE
PICTURES OF THEIR CHILDREN IN
CASE THEY WENT MISSING.
AND LASTLY WE WANTED OUR
COMMUNITY TO TELL US ANY
VOLUNTARY INFORMATION RELATED TO
POTENTIAL HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
HOUSING ACCESS INFORMATION. TO
MAKE ANY RESPONSE TO THEM MORE
EFFICIENT.
THE DRAWBACK THAT ELK GROVE
EXPERIENCED IN THIS WAS LIMITED
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THAT THE
SYSTEM WAS AVAILABLE AND THAT
OUR INITIAL GOAL WAS TO GET
TOGETHER WITH OTHER AGENCIES AND
GET THEM ON BOARD TO ESTABLISH A
WIDE REGIONAL AREA.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINTS WHICH OFFER THIS SERVICE.
IF IT WAS REGIONAL LIES TO
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN SAY THE
CITY OF ROSEVILLE BUT WORKED IN
THE CITY OF GALT.
COULD HAVE THEIR PROFILE
INFORMATION POP UP IN FRONT OF
ANY THERE ARE NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS.
IN JURISDICTIONS TO WHICH THE
CALLER LIVES WORKS OR PASSES
THROUGH.
THIS TYPE OF REGIONAL NET IS
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS NECESSARY FOR
A SERVICE LIKE THIS TO THE
ULTIMATELY BE SUCCESSFUL.
WHILE I WAS NOT WORKING IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS
TO FIELD EMERGENCY CALLS.
DURING THE INITIAL EVACUATION OF
THE AREAS AFFECTED BY THE
CAMPFIRE IN BUTTE COUNTY.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THAT IF
PROFILE INFORMATION POPULATED
FOR THOSE NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS ANSWERING THE LINES.
THERE WOULD'VE BEEN A LOT OF
HELPFUL INFORMATION AVAILABLE
EVEN WITHOUT THE CALLER SPEAKING.
IT IS NEVER AN IDEAL SITUATION
FOR CALLERS NOT TO TALK TO NINE
ONE ONE DISPATCHER BUT CERTAINLY
WOULD HAVE OFFERED AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF POTENTIAL LIFE SAVING
INFORMATION FOR THOSE
DISPATCHERS.
AS A DISPATCH SUPERVISOR FOR THE
OAK GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
AS THE STATE COORDINATOR FOR THE
TELE COMMUNICATORS SEE RESPONSE
TASK FORCE.
WHICH SENT OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DISPATCHERS FROM AROUND
THE STATE FROM THIRTY MUTUAL AID
AGENCIES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE ELEVEN IS
I BELIEVE A STATEWIDE SYSTEM
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALLERS WHO
CREATE PROFILES WILL ULTIMATELY.
MAKE PROVIDING EMERGENCY
SERVICES MORE EFFICIENT AND
COULD POTENTIALLY ASSISTANCE AND
SAVING LIVES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ASTRAZENECA I AM THE EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY WE REPRESENT
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
HOME CARE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
WHOSE -- CLIENTS WHO ARE THE
ELDERLY AND DISABLED MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY WOULD BENEFIT FROM
A PROGRAM SUCH AS THIS.
I AM I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND I VOTE FOR A.
B..
NINE ONE ONE THE MANY ALERT ACT --
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A BRIEF
BACKGROUND AS TO WHY.
THE MAIN REASON IS MY SON
[inaudible]
MANNY.
I HE IS TWENTY YEARS OLD.
HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM AND
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY AT THE
AGE OF THREE HI HE IS AT THE
MORE SEVERE END OF THE SPECTRUM.
WHERE HE HAS NONVERBAL COMBATIVE
HE DOESN'T FOLLOW VERBAL
COMMANDS?
AND HE'S A FLIGHT RISK WITH NO
FEAR OF WATER HEIGHTS CARS.
I HAD AND HE'S ALSO AN EPILEPTIC.
AND WHILE HE LOOKS VERY HANDSOME
NORMAL YOUNG MAN ON THE OUTSIDE
HE IS VERY CHILD LIKE.
HE LOVES THINGS SUCH AS CARTOONS
DISNEY MOVIES DOOR THE EXPLORA
HE LOVES MUSIC -- NICE BOUNCY
HOUSES AS BUT HE DEPENDS ON
SOMEONE FOR HIS DAILY LIVING
TASKS AS WELL.
AND IT WAS ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO
WHEN HE MANAGED TO GET OUT OF MY
HOUSE ONE OF MY OTHER CHILDREN
FORGOT TO LOCK THE GATE.
AND I'M SURE YOU CAN IMAGINE AS
MOST OF YOU ARE PROBABLY PARENTS.
THE FEAR WHEN I REALIZED THAT HE
WAS GONE.
I LUCKILY FOR ME WE DID FIND IN
ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTE WINDOW.
WHICH FELT LIKE ETERNITY.
HOWEVER WE FOUND ABOUT TWENTY
FEET AWAY FROM A BRIDGE DOWN THE
ROAD FROM MY HOUSE.
SO IN THOSE MOMENTS AFTER
GETTING HIM HOME COMING DOWN.
HARD SOMEWHAT COMING DOWN.
AT MY WILL STARTED SPENDING AND
ALL OF MY FEARS AT THAT POINT
HAD ALMOST COME TO A REALITY.
I STARTED THINKING ABOUT ALL OF
THE WHAT IFS WHAT IF HE HAD
GOTTEN INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE
BRIDGE AND SAW THE WATER BECAUSE
HE LOVES TO PLAY IN WATER.
HE WOULD HAVE JUMPED.
AND WHAT IF HE GOT HIT BY A CAR
BECAUSE HE HAS NO FEAR OF THOSE
THINGS HE JUST.
WALKS RIGHT OUT INTO THE STREET --
ALSO ONE OF A FIRST RESPONDER IN
THIS INSTANCE PRIMARILY A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WOULD HAVE
COME INTO CONTACT WITH HIM.
AND MISTAKEN HIS CALM NON
COMPLIANCE FOR JUST THAT.
BUT NOT PART OF HIS DISABILITY.
ON IT WAS AT THAT POINT MY WILL
STARTED SPENT IN AND I DECIDED I
WAS NOT GOING TO SIT BY AND LET
MY SON BECOME MANY ONE OF THE
MANY STORIES I HAD HEARD OF FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND I HAD.
HAD TO TAKE INTO ACTION.
WHAT I FELT WAS NECESSARY -- AND
KIND OF BRING FORWARD.
PUZZLE PIECES SO TO SPEAK OF
THIS BIGGER PICTURE OF
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES.
SO I STARTED DOING SOME RESEARCH
AS TO WHAT WAS AND WASN'T
HAPPENING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- I KNEW WE HAD TO
HAVE BETTER LET SYSTEMS TRAINING --
TOOLS TO BETTER HELP -- SERVER
DISABLE COMMUNITY AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
SO I REACHED OUT TO LIKE MINDED
LEGISLATORS LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND MANY OTHERS. TO
HELP ME AND FIXING THIS ISSUE.
I WILL.
AB SO I SPENT MUCH OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS MEETING WITH --
GROVE -- SANTA CLARITA AND MANY
OF THE OTHER -- AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE THAT ALREADY HAVE THE
SIMILAR THINGS IN PLACE.
HOWEVER -- WE NEED ONE STATEWIDE
COHESIVE PROGRAM -- I'D SPOKEN
WITH A POLICE OFFICER TO MANY
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT I
ASKED FOR THIS -- AND THEY WANT
IT HI PAT AS OUR CAPTAIN TELL ME
THAT WE CANNOT WAIT FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN IT HAS TO HAPPEN NOW.
AND I JUST.
I COULD GO ON FOR DAYS TALKING
ABOUT IT AND I CAN SEE YOU
GIVING ME THE EYE -- SO -- I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
SANTIAGO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE JUST A
SMALL PORTION OF MY STORY TODAY --
AND AGAIN THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ COMMITMENT TO ME FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND HELPING
ME GET THIS PAST -- AND I HUMBLY
ASK FOR YOUR ALL'S I VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND -- ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES.
MR TEAR MEMBERS THANK YOU TERESA
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARE
CAN YOU SEE P. CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION WHERE COSPONSORS
OF THE BILL HERE IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
A MYSTERY BECAUSE YOU SET THE
AMENDMENTS YES I DO I THANK YOU.
SUPPORT IT IS A SPORT WITNESSES.
TIFFANY WHITE WITH THAT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SHARE MEMBERS BRIAN NELSON ABOUT
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND ARE
PHILLIP -- UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS FOR BRING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON AMYLIN MATHIS
IS A CONCERNS -- WE'VE SEEN
RECENTLY THE MORE INFORMATION
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS HAD.
THE BETTER THEY'RE ABLE TO
ORGANIZATION AND SESSION PLEASE
THANK YOU SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS KATHY BAR HIM I AM
A MEMBER OF THE AND I MEAN I HSS
PROVIDER FOR THE U. D. W. IN
PLASTER COUNTY.
AND I HAVE.
A DISABLED SON THAT IS A TEN
MUSICIAN ORGANIZATIONALLY I HAVE
TO BE FAIR TO EVERYBODY THAT'S
WHAT THE STATE WANTS SO WHAT YOU
WANT ME TO JUST SAY I SUPPORTING
YES.
I DID SAY MY NAME KATHY AND HIM
FOR POSITIONS.
AND I AM I CARE PROVIDER I SAID
THAT -- UP FOR OUR I EIGHT
JUSTICE IN A U. D. W..
PLUS COUNTY.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS
THANK YOU.
HI AM ALISON AND I AM.
I AM ALSO A U. D. W. PROVIDER I
HSS PROVIDER AND I DO HAVE AN
ADULT SON THAT HAS DISABILITIES
A LOT LIKE IN THE STORY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
PRESIDENTE PREZ UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS ASKS ME.
AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE ELEVEN A THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO
HEAR THE LIES BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS HAVE THIS THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO CARE FOR OUR
LOVE THANK YOU.
AND I A IN I HATE THE PRESS ON I
JUST HAVE TO BE FAIR TO
EVERYBODY SO I PUT THAT THE SAID
THE ONCE I CITY OPPOSITION AS
WELL SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING.
THE NUMBER IS ZERO SON.
YEP FOR YOUR IT IT'LL BE.
OF WHEN WE HAVE IT WELL NO NO
[inaudible]
THAT'S THAT HAVE.
ALUMINUM REST MADERA.
BINGO UP WHERE IT WILL BE IN.
A AVE RIVER OWNS A CRISIS IN
NINETY UT W. AND SHE'S HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE ELEVEN THANK
YOU.
THE SABRINA STREET WITH UT W.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
MY AND WHAT AND NOW WITH YOU W.
IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S BUT HE'S A PAID A UT
W. AND HERE TO SUPPORT AB WHAT.
NINE ELEVEN ANY DAY WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME MY NAME IS SEAN A SHADY
A MEMBER OF UW I'M STRIDES FOR
ITS FROM THE SUPPORT THIS.
TO ANY MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ASSUMING THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
I APOLOGIZE I I'M SORRY THAT'S
OUR EIGHT BACK A KRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA HERE WITH CONCERNS
THAT THEY'RE NOT ADEQUATE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL
TO ENSURE THAT THE INFORMATION
SUBMITTED.
IS ONLY USED FOR THE PURPOSE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE BILL AND NOT
USED FOR OTHER PURPOSES AND ALSO
THERE'S NOT.
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT THE
INFORMATION SUBMITTED IS IN FACT
VERIFIED AND BY THAT INDIVIDUAL
AND SO WE ASK FOR AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES -- AIR CARRIERS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIAN
WE'D HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS
THANK YOU.
A QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES -- IS CRUCIAL.
HI NOT A QUESTION BUT I DO WANNA
COMMEND DONE NOT ONLY THE AUTHOR
BUT YEAH AMY AND HER STORY ABOUT
HER SON AS IT REALLY PAINTS THE
PICTURE.
UP FOR MANY PARENTS AS THEY SEE
THEIR CHILDREN GROW INTO DULTS
AND THEY WORK ON THAT BALANCE
BETWEEN INDEPENDENCE AND SAFETY.
I KNOW THAT -- WE ALSO HAVE A
GROWING COMMUNITY OF OCT TWO
STICKS TIME -- CHILDREN AND
YOUNG ADULTS AND SO THIS MEASURE --
IN THE FUTURE I THINK WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE EXPANDED TO APPLY TO
MANY OTHERS THAT OUR
PARTICULARLY AS THEY GET OLDER
THE THE ONE FACT THAT REALLY.
HITS HOME IS THE COMPLIANCE AS
FAR AS PUBLIC SAFETY WOULD GO
AND UNDERSTANDING WHO THEY MAY
BE ENCOUNTERING SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SOMEONE A GREAT BILL THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING FORWARD CERTAINLY
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
A COUPLE CONCERNS I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU -- FIRST OF ALL
LIKE TO ASK.
WHAT'S YOUR FEELING IS ABOUT --
THIS SYSTEM CREATING ADDITIONAL
LIABILITY FOR FIRST RESPONDERS
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT'S BEEN RAISED.
IS THAT A FAILURE TO UTILIZE
INFORMATION IN THE SYSTEM MIGHT
CREATE LIABILITY.
FOR A FIRST RESPONDER AND I
THINK THAT IT WOULD BE A GOOD
THING TO HAVE MAYBE SOME SAFE
HARBOR IN THE BILL ESPECIALLY
DURING A PHASE IN PERIOD.
WHEN WE GET THE SYSTEM
OPERATIONAL YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT YES I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU KNOW IT IT'S A NEW SYSTEM AS
WERE TRANS -- TRENDS.
TRENDS GOING INTO THE NEW SYSTEM
WITH NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE THE
SMART. NINE ONCE IN ORDER CAN A
JOINT IT'S IT'S VERY OPEN AND
I'M OPEN TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THE SYSTEM RIGHT.
AND AS I TALKED ABOUT IT -- I
DON'T THINK PEOPLE REALIZE.
THAT IN A DAY AND AGE NOT TO
RESPOND -- FROM MY PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCES WORKING ALBERS
INDUSTRY THERE MANY TIMES YOU
GET THAT NINE ONE ONE HANG UP
CALL THE QUESTRADE.
TO THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM SO
YOU DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A MEDICAL
AID CALL IT'S A FIRE CALL OR A
SAFETY ISSUE WITH PD.
BUT WOULDN'T BE BETTER THAT AS
REMOVING TO THIS NEXT GENERATION
OF MY ONE SYSTEM.
THAT WE GET ALL THAT RELEVANT
INFORMATION THAT HEY YOU KNOW
WHAT.
THERE IS SOMEBODY THAT
VOLUNTARILY -- PUT THEM SOUTH
PUT THEIR INFORMATION ON THE
SYSTEM SO WE KNOW.
WHAT TYPE OF PERSON WE MAY COME
INTO THAT IT COULD HAVE BEEN
THAT PERSON?
THAT WASN'T ABLE TO TALK BUT WE
HAVE THE MY ONE CARD THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE ALL THE HELP
MEDICAL INFORMATION SO WE CAN
BETTER RESPOND. TO PREPARE
OURSELVES ONCE WE ARRIVED ON THE
SCENE OF THE CALL TO PROVIDE THE
BEST TREATMENT ANSWER FOR THOSE --
PERSON THAT ARE EITHER SICK OR
INJURED.
AND IT'S KIND OF A PLACE IN A
ROAD MAP TO HOW WE GET THERE BUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
FOR THE RIGHT REASONS YEAH I
SOME OPEN.
AND IT'S SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE MOST CRITICAL FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU HAD A A MEDICATION ALLERGY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU VERY
MUCH WANT TO FIRST RESPONDERS TO
KNOW ABOUT BUT IF YOU WERE TO
PUT THAT IN. TWO VIEWS A
RIDICULOUS EXAMPLE THE DAY AFTER
THE ROLL OUT OF THE SYSTEM AND
TWO DAYS AFTER A PARAMEDIC CAME
OUT DIDN'T CHECK THAT IN ITS
PRESCRIBE THAT MEDICATION FOR
YOU.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING WHERE THAT MIGHT
CREATE -- SOME LIABILITY AND A
CAUSE OF ACTION -- FOR AGAINST
THAT FIRST RESPOND OR NO MAYBE
LONG TERM THAT'S APPROPRIATE BUT
BUT I THINK AS WE ROLL OUT WE
NEED TO BE SENSITIVE TO THAT.
I'D ONE OTHER CONCERN TO SHARE
WITH YOU AND AND THIS IS.
NOT A CRITICISM BECAUSE I
REALIZE THIS IS IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU WERE JUST
ASKED TO TAKE SO I WAS
NEGOTIATION WITH THE COMMITTEE
I'M AWARE OF THAT BUT AMONGST
THE PIECES OF INFORMATION YOU'RE
ADDING TO THE SYSTEM IS RATE THE
RACE OR ETHNICITY.
AND I KNOW WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
THE EFFORTS THAT WE'VE MADE
RECENTLY IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
TRY AND ROOT OUT RACISM IN.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT -- WE
CERTAINLY WOULDN'T WANT TO
CREATE A NEW SOURCE OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD BE USED
TO PERPETUATE RACISM.
AND I I JUST.
WHAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE SENSITIVE
TO THAT BECAUSE?
THE HOUSE THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
I I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
INFORMATION THAT WE WANT PEOPLE
TO BE AWARE OF BEFORE THEY SHOW
UP AT THE EVENT.
AND I THINK THAT'S JUST.
GIVE THE FIRST RESPONDERS A
BETTER IDEA OF THE TYPE OF
PERSON THE LOOKING FOR RIGHT AS
WE LOOK AT THE RACE AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE I'M NOT ENOUGH OF
IT UNDER CENTER INTENSE CRYING I
MEAN AND AND I WOULD HATE TO PUT
THE ONUS ON THE OTHER BECAUSE WE
DID.
A SUGGEST THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THAT'S WHY AND THE AND THE
AUTHORS ACCEPTED THEM -- I WOULD
ECHO WHAT THE AUTHOR SAID NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO DARLING WHICH
BEARS -- AND TO THE DEGREE THAT
WE'RE COLLECTING INFORMATION IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT A FIRST
RESPONDER -- SHOWS UP -- A GOOD
EXAMPLE MY PARENTS AND AND THEY
DON'T HAVE GOOD GOOD -- A GOOD
GRASP OF THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
THAT THAT THE PERSON WOULD HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN WE'RE
SPEAKING TO THIS PERSON THAT ARE
WALKING AND IF THE IF THERE
ISN'T A RESPONSE TO THE WRIST
THE LACK OF RESPONSE MIGHT
IMMEDIATELY BE.
THE FACT THAT THERE MAY BE A
LANGUAGE BARRIER AS OPPOSED AND
THAT WHICH IS VERY CERTAINLY I
COULD SEE FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE --
WHAT WHAT YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN
THAT IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
WAS NOT THE INTENT THE INTENT
WAS SOMETHING ELSE OKAY WELL?
THEN PERHAPS WE SHOULD RENAME
THAT LANGUAGE -- BUT WHAT WHAT
I'M TRYING TO AVOID IS I MEAN
GOD FOR BID WE HAVE ANY.
FIRST RESPONDERS THAT WOULD LOOK
AT SOMEONE'S RACE AND BE LESS
LIKELY TO RESPOND TO PROVIDE
ACCURATE SERVICE I HOPE THAT
THERE'S NO ONE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT COULD BE TRUE UP -- IF
THERE IS THOUGH I WOULD HATE TO
ENABLE THEM BY MAKING THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE WE WOULD
BOTH BE ON THE SAME SIDE IS
CERTAINLY WE WOULD TAKE A LOOK
AT BUT THAT BUT THAT THE INTENT
THAT -- THE AUTHOR ECHOED IN
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
INTENT THAT I SUGGESTED -- WERE
THE LINES THAT WE ARE VIEWING
THIS ENTERING THIS OKAY WELL I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
CONCERN WITH YOU BUT ASSEMBLYMAN
AS AS A GREAT BILL AND WHICH YOU
ARE.
THE BEST OF LUCK IN
APPROPRIATIONS GET THAT THROUGH
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A SYSTEM
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ WHO DO I TO
CLOSE OUR CHECK REST FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I I THINK.
WELL THE FIRST IN A SECOND --
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BURN A HOLE THAT.
BONTA BRO.
BRO I CERVANTES TING.
HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW.
LOW ON AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGH. SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO MEASURES OUT
IMAGE AGAR CURRY.
BELIEVE YOU'RE IN THE CROWD.
WE LIKE THE PRESENT ON AB.
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WELL SHOULDN'T
LOUISVILLE RIGHT THERE.
WE HAVE A FIRST ALL THE WAY TO A
FIFTH.
AND I'M GONNA MAKE THIS SO SHORT
OF JUST AS THAT YOU KNOW WE DID
THE BROADBAND BILL WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
THE BROADBAND COUNCIL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROBERT
SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION I'LL MAKE THIS REAL
QUICK JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
BUSINESS AND COMPETING IN AN
INCREASINGLY GLOBAL ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS RANCHERS.
NEED RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET SERVICE IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE NECESSITY.
AND ROLL BROADBAND NETWORKS
FOSTER MORE EFFICIENT AND
ECONOMICAL AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS A LEAVE IT AT THAT
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES
I ASSUME NO OPPOSITION
ADDITIONAL POSITION WITNESSES.
A QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NOTICING THAT WE HAVE A FIRST
THROUGH A FIFTH WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU A MAN SAID TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DUPONT'S TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BURN A HOLE THAT.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
THROAT I CERVANTES TING.
HOLDEN KAMLAGER-DOVE OF LOVE.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I'D RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SEVEN ZERO MEASURES
OUT SEVEN ZERO MEASURES OUT WITH
THE SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
REGULATIONS [inaudible]
OKAY.
PROBLEM FIRST AND A SECOND A TO
A TO DROP THE COMMITTEE RULES
[inaudible]
SECOND SECOND.
LET'S AS ANY COMMENTS SOMEONE A
CALL FOR THE SANTIAGO I'M SORRY
MR ABILITY I APOLOGIZE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO ODD.
WE'RE GONNA BE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE NEW COMMITTEE
RULES AND I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW WHY BECAUSE THERE
WEREN'T VERY MANY CHANGES MADE
BUT ONE CHANGE WAS MADE WAS TO
SECTION TWO A TO THE RULES WHICH
REGARDS.
INITIAL REFERRAL TO COMMITTEE
AND THE SENTENCE THAT WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT SAYS ONCE
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE MAY SET
THE BILL FOR ANY AVAILABLE
HEARING DATE AT THE DISCRETION
OF THE CHAIR.
LAST YEAR IT SAID AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE COMMITTEE
IMPLYING THAT THE DATE WOULD BE
AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
COMMITTEE.
CHANGING THAT TO THE CHAIR
IMPLIES THAT A BILL MAY NOT BE
SAID IF THE SHARE DOESN'T WANT
IT SAID AND NOT THAT I WOULD
THINK THIS OF YOU MISTER CHAIR
BUT IN THE FUTURE WE MIGHT HAVE
A CHAIR THAT THAT BELIEVES THE
BILL SHOULD BE HELD AT THE
DISCRETION.
OF THE CHAIR NOT HURT AT ALL AND
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT EVERY
BILL THAT'S REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE OUGHT TO GET A HEARING
EVEN IF IT'S VOTED DOWN AT THAT
HEARING SO.
I WILL BE RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
FOR THAT REASON.
I CAN APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A FIRST AND A SECOND MAN
SICK TAKE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
I OBERNOLTE HEALTH RULES.
OBERNOLTE NO BURN A HOLE THAT
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
I HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
HAS NOT BURDEN.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
SORRY MR CARE IT'S JUST THAT ONE
SPECIFIC I'VE ALREADY HAD TWO
BILLS NOT LOOKING FORWARD.
WE SIMPLY ADOPTED THE HOUSE
RULES WE'VE ALL ALREADY VOTED ON
I DON'T AGREE WITH THEM SO.
QUIRK SILVA NUMB.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGH.
IT'S ON CALL.
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A COUPLE
MEASURES ON CALL THE WAY TO GO
THROUGH.
MA'AM SECRETARY BEGIN.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB [inaudible]
ONE EIGHT THREE BONTA
[inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING I HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF LOW.
LOW ON MY FOR DOING THIS
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I MEASURES ON CALL.
MY STILL ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT BUT A WHOLE VAT
[inaudible]
BONTA.
CERVANTES TING.
TING I HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
WHICH IS OUT.
MEASURES OUT.
I DO NUMBER THREE AB.
FOUR NINE SEVEN BURN A HOLE THAT
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING.
TING I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I SEVEN ZERO
MOTIONS SEVEN ZERO MEASURES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO BURN A HOLE THAT
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING.
TING I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOT VOTING.
LOW.
LOW I EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO
MEASURES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINE ONE ONE
MEASURES OUT FOR ADAMS BURN A
HOLE THAT.
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
TING.
TING I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MEASURES.
MEASURES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB ONE ONE THREE
TWO MEASURES ON CALL.
BUT A WHOLE THAT [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
TING.
TING I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CAN LOG INTO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW.
LOW I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I TEN ZERO MEASURES
OUT TEN ZERO MEASURES OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB ONE FIVE
ONE FOUR MEASURES ON CALL.
BUT A WHOLE VAT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT I BONTA
[inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
BONTA I BONTA HIGH [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
TING.
TING I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CAN LOG A DOVE.
I'M LIKE A DOUBLE I LOVE
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I ELEVEN TWO ZERO
MEASURES OUT LEIN'S YOUR
MESSAGE OUT.
COMMITTEE RULES ON CALL.
BURN A HOLE THAT.
THE WHOLE Và I BONTA
[inaudible]
BONTA I BROUGH [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HI.
CERVANTES SIGH HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW. EIGHT TO
TEN PEOPLE SO DR. EIGHTY TWO CAN
BE RULES ADOPTED.
THE MEASURE ON CALL.
I DO NUMBER ONE AB ONE EIGHT
THREE MEASURE ON CALL BONTA HI
BONTA I CERVANTES.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB [inaudible]
ONE EIGHT THREE CERVANTES SIGH
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I NINETY FOUR
MEASURES. NINETY FOUR MEASURES
OUT GIVES A QUICK SECOND TO
REGROUP OF DONE THIS TWICE NOW.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT MEASURES OUT BUT A WHOLE
VAT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT I BONTA HI
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI.
ITEM NUMBER THREE A BEFORE NINE
SEVEN MEASURE IS OUT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT.
I REMEMBER THREE AB.
FOUR NINE SEVEN BURN BURN A HOLE
THAT NOT VOTING.
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES NOT VOTING.
I'D NUMBER FOUR AB EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO MEASURES OUT.
BUT A WHOLE Và.
BUT A WHOLE BUT I BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I RODRIGUEZ.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. NINE ONE
ONE MEASURE IS OUT.
BURN A HOLE THAT.
THE WHOLE Và I BONTA HI BONTA I
CERVANTES. SEVEN TO SIGN.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB.
ONE ONE THREE TWO MEASURE IS OUT
BURN A HOLE THAT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT I BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CERVANTES [inaudible]
CERVANTES I I NUMBER SEVEN AB
ONE FIVE ONE FOUR CERVANTES
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
CERVANTES AYE.
LEAVE THE ROOM.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR TWO
MINUTES.
IT'S MY PHONE HELP BY
[inaudible]
YEAH
RODRIGUEZ BACK.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB.
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO PURPOSES OF
ADAM RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGH MEASURES OUT.
MEMBERS THIS CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS TODAY.
THE MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND I CAN FIND THE BY THE
NUMBERS.
AND THE OFFICIAL SITE
[inaudible]
YOUR AVAILABLE